a few days ago ign india
released an article where they spoke to
massive entertainment senior game
developer
trick dempsey in this video i'd like to
discuss
a few of the points they talked about
that are found interesting in relation
to the law of the game
first one wasn't really a surprise to me
as i've discussed it a number of times
in other videos in the past
but over the last couple of years i've
been seeing a lot of comments and
speculation around the events and
characters relating to either tom clancy
or ubisoft titles to be fair this is
probably the first time it's been
addressed by an official source
since before the division 1 was first
released so it's nice to have an
up-to-date confirmation on the topic
although there are a number of easter
eggs dotted throughout the ubisoft games
like logos watches and posters
referencing the division and vice versa
trick admits that these are really just
playful notes towards other games under
the ubisoft umbrella
she goes on to talk about how even
within the tom clancy family
the division does not coincide with
other series one of the easiest ways to
see this is to look at the presidential
timelines
in each universe and note who's in power
and when
although some of these politicians have
the same names they're actually
different characters
this again is another nod to other
titles
when asked about the structure and
management of the law trek gives us what
i think
is an interesting response while there
is a network of internal law
documentation that holds the true
stories of the characters
factions locations and events there are
two golden rules
nothing is canon until it appears in
game and the only reliable narrator
is the player agents experience
just because something exists in an old
planning document does not make it true
and the agent should not trust the words
of characters with an agenda
any character who records or broadcasts
something does so with the intent to
manipulate their audience
unless the agents themselves see
something happen with their very own
eyes
they should be careful about trusting
too deeply
a lot of us myself included often fall
into the trap of taking the intel and
comms
as the absolute truth but what trick is
saying is that unless we've witnessed it
with our own eyes
it could have been left for us to find
to intentionally mislead or distract us
towards false conclusions suddenly my
tinfoil hat speculation videos don't
seem so crazy after all
well not all of them anyway in fact it
actually opens up a whole bunch more for
me
characters with an agenda this could be
quite a number of characters
even the division agency itself given
everything that's happened and who is
technically still in charge of them
who knows how far this goes is the shd
intel we've gathered over time
compromised as well
given what we've seen recently with the
sudden and abrupt end to the feylau
manhunt
and the message from the studio
essentially saying that they'd plan to
stop releasing new content
it was pleasing to see tricks say that
they're not going to be providing total
closure to the story
any time soon over the last year a
number of major characters have been
killed off
but we'll be seeing some of the
supporting characters being given a
larger role
the sokolov family is still active and
barden schaefer is in custody
she goes on to say the division may not
have hierarchy but it's still reeling
from the loss
of one of its most prominent agents and
the crisis that activated the division
in the first place
is far from over so take that as you
will
but i'm still hanging on to the fact
that fey lau may still be alive
but i won't rant about that again here
i've talked about that enough already in
another video
when she says loss i'm gonna take that
as a loss of her as an agent within the
shd ranks
because she went rogue and joined the
black tusk yeah
i might be clutching a little we'll see
fun fact i actually met trick dempsey in
sweden at the pre-warlords of new york
release
media event sadly i was so eager and
excited to get into playing the new
content
i really didn't have the chance to have
a good chat with her but what i did take
away
is that she's a bloody nice person
especially when considering at the time
she was dealing with a bunch of annoying
gamers trying their best to break the
game
anyway this was just a quick video
summing up what was talked about and
maybe giving some context behind some of
the
different videos i'll be putting out
over the coming weeks hopefully you
found this as intriguing as i did
and i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh